all divisions okay in this example I
realize it's not that bad because I
chose some pretty low powers okay but as
you increase the powers of this guy
right this takes forever
it takes up like half a page because you
need lighting so much stuff okay
so synthetic division I know is probably
optional to you guys you need nine maybe
did get taught it but you didn't learn
it because people can teach things
without you buddy yeah so I'm gonna go
through it now because it's so much of a
time saver because you're 11 you can
feel it so how does it work let's take
the same question okay the first thing
you do is you write up to vision so I
write it upside down there's only one
reason why you write it upside down and
so you don't confuse it with this one
okay all right now what are you write
down there here's where it starts to
save time for starters instead of
writing X plus 1 X plus 1 is up it's
about it's also polynomial right I
actually want to write the solution to X
plus 1 right so if this was X plus 1
equals 0 what would its solution be
minus 1 right so sometimes this is
called the 0 of X plus 1 I find out
really confusing because the 0 is minus
that's weird for me I I'm trying to
think about what solves this equation ok
minus 1 now in the same way I'm going to
look at this instead of writing out the
whole thing I just write out the pots
that matter right namely the
coefficients they're the pots which
actually define what happens in this
division
okay so I've got a there's a one hiding
there right so I'm going to write 1 5 6
okay and just before I go any further if
we were dividing by for instance x
squared plus 6 and there's no 5x there
okay just like with long division
there's actually an X term hiding in
there
right it's just that there are zero of
them right so in that case
excuse me you'd write 1 0 6 you can't
leave it out of everything okay
oh and naturally if you've got some
the coefficients here that we named it
up here so I was that question yeah if
if it was zero X so as inductor skip it
that's all I'm saying okay all right now
how does it actually work well the first
thing you do and this bits a bit
difference so you just take this number
okay that leading coefficient right you
just write it down here okay as you'll
see in a second
this middle road here this is gonna be
out working it's gonna correspond to all
of this stuff okay
and this last through here this is going
to be the actual solution that we get at
the end which corresponds to here all
right we read this number down and then
I'm going to do excuse me everything I
did with long division but kind of kind
of do me the reverse okay because this
plus one is turned into a minus one all
right so before we did this multiplying
thing that's how things come from the
top to the bottom so I'm gonna take 1
minus 1 you multiply to me you get minus
1 you write that over here okay because
it's gonna tell me what the next number
is okay now here I subtracted right I
subtracted go from one line to the other
because I turned this into a minus 1
I'm not going to subtract I am going to
add for the reverse step okay so five
plus negative one okay okay now I'm
gonna do it again just like I did
everything for multiply it by this minus
4 then 6 plus negative 4 is 2 okay now
I'm finished sort of okay now remember
all I wrote is the coefficients up here
so this is just the coefficients right
but think with me I'm dividing degree 2
by degree 1 right so what I'm gonna get
at the end or to have degree 1 okay so
these numbers here correspond to the
coefficients of the polynomial with
degree 1
that's my doctor okay
hey that's it right now I could just
write x plus 4 Omega - okay which
thankfully is exactly the same thing we
got over there okay but let's just go
back over that because I know some of
you have seen it before
how does it work sorry yeah okay I
should have probably put that at the top
this is called synthetic division
just like my fixation with games I'm
actually well synthesis actually just me
putting things together yeah Wilson
sym is is about combinations of things
all right
like seek like syncopations and anyway
okay so synthetic division
let me just rehearse the steps again
okay number one take this leading
coefficient and you just write it down
no change okay and then the steps begin
where you start to repeat it okay so you
take that one multiply and you do again
multiply okay it's faster for two
reasons number one you just have to
write less less you number two
addition surprisingly is actually faster
than factoring people often screw up the
subtraction particularly this double
negative in here
this tends to be a less error-prone
method okay all right now the benefits
you would not say obvious because it was
a pretty short question come on yeah all
right so let's do a longer example okay
and we'll actually do with that bigger
bigger power so you'll see the benefit
yeah
okay it's been division always a lot
faster answer when you are dividing by
something specific so if the factor that
I'm after or sorry I should say factor
if the divisor is something like this
actually pick this very carefully it's
two things number one it's linear right
if you graphed X plus one straight line
okay so if I were dividing by say x
squared plus one I've seen that division
will work but Nitze modified and twisted
to turn in and done quite well for soon
we're not only as a linear it's morning
it means the leading coefficient is 1
hence it's Monica
so in other words a degree 1 lead
coefficient 1 right now the reason why
it still work worth letting this method
even though it seems to only work with a
very specific kind of question is
because this specific kind of question
is the one we always do and that's
something we'll address thank you